this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skillshare learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on the link in the description
well it finally happened donald trump's
taxes have been released or more
specifically they've been leaked
and the information contained inside
helps paint a picture of why the
president wanted to hide the information
for so long
since at least 2015 americans have
wanted to know one thing about donald
trump's finances
does he pay taxes or not the new york
times has now answered this question
president trump has paid zero taxes for
10 of the last
15 years he paid 750 in taxes the year
he became president and the year after
and even then it was only because his
accountants wanted him to pay
something he didn't understand the code
nor would he have
had the time and the patience to learn
the provisions no he knew that we would
produce the lowest possible tax for him
within the law
he deducted personal expenses like
seventy thousand dollars in hair styling
services
he paid hundreds of thousands of dollars
to his children who he was also
employing as w-2 employees
and before he became president he was
hemorrhaging money
gobs and gobs of money so president
trump pays basically zero in taxes
because almost
all of his businesses operate at a huge
loss on
paper where he is perpetually inflating
the costs and minimizing his
income president trump portrays himself
as a populist but he operates more like
bernie madoff a guy who cooked the books
to make himself look like a genius
until his entire venture collapsed but
are these activities
actually tax crimes that could get
president trump in legal trouble or even
jail time
or is it just legal and smart tax
avoidance strategies by a financial pro
working their magic
over the tax code well we finally have a
window into answering these questions
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a tax lawyer
because the president's finances and the
finances of the trump organization are a
web of interlocking companies
all of which appear to use extremely
suspicious
tax and financial strategies now it
appears that the new york times has
access to the president's personal tax
returns going back
20 years as well as the tax returns of
the different trump organization
llcs of which there are hundreds of them
which are interrelated to the president
because
of their pass-through nature we'll
probably cover the liability of this
whistleblower in a different video but
suffice to say the information that they
divulged
appears to be accurate now the
whistleblower's liability is an
interesting question but under the
pentagon papers case new york times
versus the united states
unless the new york times suborned the
actual leaking and or the whistleblowing
and
actually facilitated the actual act of
disclosing the
tax returns the new york times is almost
certainly free to cover the story and
will probably escape any kind of
liability regardless of whether
the person who actually blew the whistle
and
or leaked the information has personal
liability which they might
so the question for the public is can we
come to any legal conclusions based on
the information that was divulged
well let's start with a tax code title
26 section 7201 of the tax code creates
the federal crime of tax evasion
which has historically been the main tax
revenue offense there are two potential
offenses under section 7201
subsection 1 the willful attempt to
evade or defeat the assessment of
attacks
and 2 the willful attempt to evade or
defeat the payment of attacks
the most common attempt to evade or
defeat tax is the affirmative act of
filing a false return that omits income
and or claims deductions for the
taxpayer that they're not entitled to
the tax reported on the return is
falsely understated and creates some
deficiency
and when someone under-reports their
income this is
an attempt to evade or defeat tax by
evading the correct assessment of that
tax
to prove these crimes the government
must prove that the defendant engaged in
some affirmative conduct that was
designed to mislead the irs
or conceal the tax liability or assets
and often this comes in the form of
deductions that you're not
actually allowed to take or personal
expenses that you say are a business
expense
and when there is a pattern of
overstating or inflating deductions the
irs can
charge you with tax evasion and this may
be a problem area for the president
because for years president trump has
classified most of the money he spends
on his lavish lifestyle
as a business expense for example
president trump claimed the cost of air
travel and car services
to and from his private homes as a
write-off he itemized over 70 thousand
dollars in hair styling fees for
whatever is on his head he also deducted
expenses for ivanka's hair and makeup
artist to the tune of nearly 100 000
hair and makeup deductions are pretty
straightforward deductions a haircut or
makeup application isn't deductible
unless the use is limited exclusively to
the business appearance itself and
that's hard with a haircut
because the haircut lasts after you have
done the thing that you're doing
and then there's things like using an
investment property for your own
personal purposes
president trump took a deduction for an
investment property located in bedford
new york
this home which the trump family calls
seven springs has been in the trump
family since 1996
and the trump offspring have bragged
about spending summers at the 200 acre
estate
according to the trump organization
website quote today seven springs is
used as a retreat for the trump family
if it's a personal retreat for the trump
family how can it be an investment
property
as an investment property trump has been
able to write off 2.2 million dollars in
property taxes since 2014.
we don't have any evidence that seven
springs is actually being rented out or
developed which is typically how you
would show that a property is an
investment property rather than a
residence
instead the property is described by the
trump organization website in loving
terms complete with a photo spread
emphasizing its opulence
and trump's own tax declarations also
work against this claim of seven springs
as an investment property
one year after he made the designation
he claimed a tax deduction on the
property for a charitable easement a
charitable or conservation easement is
another way of creating a tax shelter
but
basically you can give the government or
public interest rights to your property
such as the right to prohibit
development or
a property to preserve the nature
surrounding it the charitable easement
on seven springs precluded from being
developed
and then there's things like potentially
bogus consulting fees
companies are allowed to deduct
consulting fees from their income
because they are a business expense this
reduces the tax bill because
the income that is taxed is lowered by
the amount of the consulting fees just
like any other business cost
so if trump's businesses deduct
legitimate consulting fees that is not
by itself tax evasion
however the trump organization
consistently reports that about 20
of its total income was paid to
consultants and this applies across all
projects
so when trump made five million dollars
in income on a hotel deal in azerbaijan
he reported 1.1 million dollars in
consulting fees
in dubai he made three million dollars
in income on a deal but reported six
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
consulting fees
these fees reduce income and thus reduce
income tax but
on deals where you don't own the
property and you're only making money on
the licensing of your brand as trump was
doing with these foreign deals
the last thing you want is a huge 20
consulting fee
unless you're also benefiting from that
consulting fee personally
it's also suspicious that the fee is
approximately the same regardless of the
size of the deal and the relative lack
of need for
consultants but further inquiry would be
needed to get to the bottom of this
and let's put aside the problematic
nature of a president getting foreign
income
from effectively dictatorships because
there's even more damning information
involving consulting fees linked to
ivanka trump
ivanka has a formal position at the
trump organization for which she gets a
salary but at the same time it appears
that trump's company once paid
747 000 in fees to an unnamed consultant
for hotel projects in hawaii and
vancouver
coincidentally when ivanka trump later
filed public disclosure forms in 2017
she listed a payment for the identical
amount so it looks like ivanka
an employee of the trump organization
also got paid a hefty consulting fee
through a consulting company that she
co-owned would this raise a red flag
with the irs
absolutely if ivanka received a
consulting fee on the same project that
she managed as an employee of the trump
organization
which is what the times alleges this
looks like evidence of fraud anytime a
company pays a family member consulting
fees
it looks like the family is conspiring
to hide income consulting fees
being paid to family members also looks
like gifts which aren't deductible and
in fact
if the fees were gifts then trump would
have liability for paying gift
tax the bottom line is that paying a
family member employee through a shell
corporation
could be a way to avoid gift tax and a
way to avoid payroll taxes
and it doesn't appear that ivanka is the
only adult trump child who engaged in
shady practices
that brings us to legal fees for don jr
the irs says that legal fees can be
deducted when they are directly related
to operating your business but this does
not
include legal fees paid to defend
charges that arise from participation in
a political campaign
however the tax records show that the
trump organization wrote off business
expenses paid to criminal defense
lawyers
who represented donald trump jr during
the russia investigation
the lawyer received at least 1.9 million
dollars in 2017 and 2018
and trump wrote off about 260 thousand
dollars it paid to william and jensen
a second law firm hired to represent
trump jr as you might recall a lot of
the russian investigation was related to
meetings that don jr had with people
promising dirt on hillary clinton so it
doesn't appear that this could be a
legitimate business expense
these are all potential examples of the
most simple form of tax evasion
deducting expenses as business expenses
that are not actually
for your business it's possible that
some of these deductions might be
defensible but it would be an uphill
battle
tax experts often say that it's very
difficult to surmise tax evasion on the
face of the returns and that
one usually needs to dig into the actual
expenses and deductions before
concluding anything so take the new york
times analysis with a grain of salt but
that said almost every professional says
that some of the items in the trump
returns are so brazen to be almost
certainly improper
but it's possible for justifications for
them of course
this is one of the reasons why
historically presidents released their
taxes to avoid
even the appearance of impropriety and
also on the other hand
these are only the seemingly improper
deductions on the face of the returns
themselves if you actually dug into the
underlying expenses and deductions that
appear to be proper you might find
things that are even worse
now in fairness these potentially
inflated potentially improper deductions
make trump's businesses look less
profitable than they might actually be
and one additional point a lot of
experts are taking these returns at face
value since the new york times is not
releasing the underlying documentation
but given the improprieties on the
surface
it's almost certain that the underlying
numbers themselves are wrong to what
extent
we don't know now a lot of these things
look bad but it's important to note that
it can be incredibly difficult to
prove the crime of tax evasion because
most of these crimes require the mental
state of willfulness we talk about
mental states on this channel a lot
because
almost every criminal law requires a
certain mental state a men's
raya to prove the crime itself and
here willfulness is defined as quote the
voluntary intentional violation of a
known duty this is known in the law as a
specific
intent crime that comes from the case of
cheek vs united states which is a really
interesting supreme court case
where a tax professor john l cheek
failed to file tax returns
and was convicted of tax evasion but the
court held that his good faith belief
that
he wasn't violating the tax law based on
a misunderstanding caused by the
complexity of the tax law
actually negated the willfulness element
and
that applies even if that belief is
irrational or completely unreasonable
so this is one of those rare cases where
having a misunderstanding of the law or
sometimes ignorance of the law actually
can be
a defense which is pretty rare for
obvious reasons
but also note that the court has ruled
that an actual belief that the tax law
is invalid or unconstitutional
is not a good faith belief based on a
misunderstanding of the tax law so
that's not a defense so sorry for all of
you sovereign citizens out there
and another thing that's incredibly
important in this context is what the
tax preparer tells the tax filer
often people use the defense of relying
on their tax professional for
the advice about what the tax law is or
is not which
can also provide a defense but the
bottom line is this is a subjective test
a defendant's good faith belief that
he's
not violating the tax law no matter how
objectively unreasonable or
stupid that is can be a defense in some
tax prosecutions
and to try and keep my sanity i'm going
to try to refrain from putting myself in
the head of donald trump
and who knows what mental state he had
or did not have when he was filing his
taxes and
claiming all of these various deductions
which brings us to the more complicated
but just as serious potential crimes
under title
18 regarding a refund tax fraud cases
are distinguishable from those involving
false claims for a tax refund
which are generally prosecuted as
violations under 18 usc 286
which is conspiracy to defraud the
government by obtaining or aiding to
obtain the payment or allowance of any
false fictitious or fraudulent claim
and 18 usc 287 making or presenting
false fictitious or fraudulent claims
upon or against the government
the new york times investigation
uncovered trump tax refund which is
currently the subject of an irs audit
and president trump wasn't lying when he
said his finances have been under audit
for an extremely long time
and this requires a bit of background
trump made his reputation in the 80s and
90s through lavish properties and
casinos
however the businesses lost over a
billion dollars and four of them filed
for bankruptcy
in 1995 trump declared a tax loss of
more than 900 million dollars related to
his atlantic city casinos
and the irs let trump offset the profits
of his businesses in the future
by using his past losses so you can
offset 900 million dollars in profit
using 900 in losses the tax loss
carryovers from the casinos came in
handy reducing the trump organization's
tax bill to zero
once the company started doing well
again now put a pin in this 900 million
dollar loss because we're going to come
back to that but even after the company
recovered from the casino implosion it
lost big money on the 15 golf courses
that trump started buying in 2000.
trump reported that the golf courses
collectively lost over 315 million
dollars
but were these losses really legitimate
the times report says that from 2016 to
2017
general and administrative expenses at
the bedminster golf club alone had it
increased by five
times now why would business expenses
increase five times on businesses that
were failing and never generated a
profit
and well it's possible that someone
purposefully inflated the expenses
inflating expenses on a failing business
is a classic money laundering tactic
which
you would know if you've ever seen the
show ozark now the prospect of money
laundering is beyond the scope of this
video but i'm betting that we haven't
heard the last of this and i recommend
checking out the reporting of adam
davidson
who looks at the trump properties across
the world and what he sees is a
continual pattern of
failing businesses needing a cash
infusion getting a cash infusion as a
loan from donald trump personally and
then that money basically disappearing
to parts unknown
which might be money laundering we'll
have to see
and not to mention trump's incredibly
suspicious foreign income
for example trump used to own the miss
universe pageant which lost millions in
both
2012 and 2014 but right in the middle in
2013
trump made millions because of a
one-time payment from the agrilog family
russian billionaires who have close ties
to vladimir putin
a huge one-time payment in a
money-losing venture could be an
overpayment
or it could be an effort to funnel money
for another reason
but what we do know is with these
massive losses what saved trump's
businesses from going belly up
was revenues from the apprentice and a
few profits generated from trump tower
one of the few pieces of real estate
that he actually made a profit on
and this cash infusion from the
apprentice was good news for the trump
organization
but it also meant that for the first
time ever president trump had a big tax
bill
and trump had to pay 70 million dollars
in taxes and he paid it but in 2010
trump told the irs that oh by the way
back in 2008 and 2009
his businesses happened to lose about
1.4 billion dollars
trump claimed that this huge loss
entitled him to a full refund of the
income taxes he had paid in 2005
2006 and 2007. and amazingly the irs
quickly paid out this massive refund
over 70 million dollars
and state and local governments followed
suit giving him back an additional 21
million dollars
trump went from telling the irs that he
was doing well to suddenly losing
another 1.4 billion dollars and where
did these heretofore unknown business
losses come from
well remember that 900 million dollar
abandonment loss he suffered as a result
of the atlantic city casinos in 2009 he
reported that he abandoned his
disastrous casinos which filed for
bankruptcy and when you abandon a
business you can take a deduction for
some of the losses as long as you don't
receive
anything of value in other words you
have to truly give it up for nothing of
value in exchange
and according to irs publication 544
sales and other dispositions of assets
abandonment losses from business or
investment property are generally
deductible as ordinary losses meaning
you get
a one-to-one deduction on all of the
losses that you suffered
as long as the abandonment is not
treated as a sale or exchange of
anything of value but
the times reports and public records
show that donald trump actually did get
something of value in exchange for his
old interest in the bankrupt atlantic
city casinos
he actually got a five percent stake in
the casino's successor company
so this tax refund of over 70 million
dollars is being audited and has been
audited for basically a decade and tax
law actually requires that all refunds
of more than two million dollars get
approval from congress's joint committee
on taxation
and that's where this matter has been
stalled for several years
we don't know exactly why this has not
been resolved but the word politics
almost certainly comes to mind
and recall that for over a year we've
known of an irs whistleblower that says
a member of the treasury department
tried to interfere with an audit
of donald trump or mike pence it seems
that these two things
might be related if trump loses the
audit which it appears he should
he'll be on the hook to repay not just
the 72 million but also fees and
interest bringing the total to over
100 million dollars in repayment that
alone could bankrupt the
undercapitalized president
so now we get into the meat and potatoes
of the matter did donald trump commit
tax fraud
tax fraud is generally not that
difficult to understand although there
are certainly legal ways to limit your
tax
exposure we'll get to those in a minute
and arguably people
are perfectly allowed to pay the minimum
amount in taxes that they
legally have to pay there are also clear
prohibitions against lying to the irs
not that president trump has ever been
caught lying but let's talk about making
false statements
section 7206 of a tax code deals with
tax fraud and making false statements to
the irs
these violations typically result from a
taxpayer falsely inflating deductions or
underreporting
income on federal income tax returns to
reduce or avoid
tax burden and a section 7206 felony
prosecution is not limited to tax
returns it deliberately applies to quote
any return statement or other document
required by the internal revenue code or
applicable regulations though note that
convicting someone and providing false
or fraudulent information to the irs
still requires a showing of willfulness
which we discussed earlier but it can be
easier to prove than
outright tax evasion in the false
information context
but you still have to show willfulness
and under united states versus clareborn
neither a showing of careless disregard
nor gross negligence and signing a tax
return will suffice
but it's not all smooth sailing for the
tax filer on the other hand
willfulness can be inferred from the
rest of the tax documents and from
circumstantial evidence
and proof of a pattern of falsities
supports an inference of willfulness
under united states versus conlon
and while some have argued that trump
can't form the requisite mental state
because he's so all over the place
there is a presumption that you know
what's in your taxes when you sign it
and liability for lying to the irs is
not limited to the taxpayer alone it
includes people who prepared the returns
corporate officers and even tax shelter
promoters so in the trump world many
people could be on the hook for these
returns like president trump's
accountants alan weisselberg cfo of the
trump organization is probably also on
the hot seat
and during a deposition related to a
lawsuit against trump university
weisselberg said only five people had
the authority to sign checks for the
company donald trump
donald trump jr eric trump ivanka trump
and himself
and you might recall that former trump
lawyer michael cohen also set up a shell
company to conceal the hush money
payments to porn stars and coordinate
strategies with the national enquirer a
process that
probably also involved making false
statements because spoiler alert there
isn't a line item related to the payment
of stormy daniels so it looks like
those payments were tried to be hidden
in normal
business operating expenses but actual
preparation of a false
return is not necessary to sustain a
conviction just supplying false
information can be enough in some cases
for conviction
of particular interest to donald trump
as a real estate magnate is united
states versus lefkowitz where the
defendant a manager of several real
estate limited
partnerships lied to his accountants
that the projects were pre-leased to
qualified low-income tenants
and therefore the limited partnerships
could begin taking tax credits when the
units were placed in service
that guy was convicted because he gave
false information to the limited
partnerships causing them to file
fraudulent returns
but let's take a moment now to talk
about lawful tax avoidance
a lot of the president's defenders claim
that trump is doing what all successful
businesses do just
exploit legal loopholes to reduce
taxation and there's a lot of people who
argue i think persuasively that
no individual or corporation has an
obligation to pay any more taxes than
they are legally required to do
and tax avoidance is just the legitimate
minimizing of taxes
and maximizing after-tax income using
methods included in the tax code
and lots of businesses avoid taxes by
taking all legitimate deductions and tax
credits and
sheltering as much income as possible
this is all legal
the irs even has a cheat sheet
summarizing the difference between
avoidance and
tax evasion which is illegal a tax
loophole is tax avoidance
a loophole is usually a deliberate
clause in the tax laws that
legislators created to reduce certain
people's taxes and we can argue whether
that's a good idea or not but
a lot of the tax code is written
specifically to give benefits to
certain groups or individuals and since
the tax code is so complex
savvy tax experts have found ways to
lower taxes for their clients without
breaking the law taking advantages of
the law as written
and i have absolutely no doubt that some
of trump's deductions were legal
but the idea that trump is just a genius
who is acting like
other business geniuses should probably
be scrutinized
so let's talk about the actually
uncontroversial idea that business
losses
offset the taxes on uh business profit
if president trump is actually losing
lots and lots of money
and then taking that deduction is this
really a smart tax maneuver well
actually
no but during a presidential debate in
2016 president trump said
i have a write-off a lot of its
depreciation which is a wonderful charge
i love depreciation
and that makes sense because
depreciation allows the owner to
take depreciation deductions on the
property that's probably still gaining
value for example
if you own a property that's worth a
million dollars even if it's
appreciating in value you're allowed to
deduct
a certain amount of the value of that
property per year so if you have a
property on fifth avenue in manhattan
for example it may depreciate for tax
purposes but it'll keep
gaining value and this is all basic
stuff that you learn even
playing monopoly and we can argue over
whether real estate developers should be
allowed to take depreciation on an asset
that
actually is going to exist for a very
very long time and is actually
appreciating in value but
that's actually the law and that's why
inheriting established properties in the
new york city real estate market with no
debt attached like donald trump did from
his father fred can be so lucrative
you're allowed to take a whole bunch of
deductions from the physical property
of the real estate in new york however
there's a big distinction between a
sensible depreciation deduction
and being forced to take a deduction
because of actual business losses that
you suffered marty ginsberg who was the
husband of ruth bader ginsburg was
considered a spectacular tax lawyer and
professor
and he authored a famous article called
the leaky tax shelter
where he made the point that the key to
a tax shelter is
not actually suffering the losses that
you deduct
ginsburg joked that a bad tax shelter
idea was saying hey
give me a million dollars of your money
and i'll run away to it with a country
where you can't get me
and then you have a million dollar theft
deduction the point is that your goal
isn't losing money then deducting the
money that you lost that doesn't make
you a genius or even particularly shrewd
since 2000 trump lost more than 315
million dollars at golf courses like
trump national doral
and the washington hotel which opened in
2016 and has lost more than 55 million
dollars
across the world his golf courses are
hemorrhaging money the vast majority of
the losses appear to be real
losses not magic deductions conjured up
by a financial whiz
in other words his economic losses far
outweigh his tax losses
trump's businesses are pretty simple
real estate and licensing
and he appears to be exceedingly bad at
it but as the president and his adult
offspring employees like to point out
part of the game is to show bigger tax
losses than you actually incurred so
these returns do in fact
overestimate the losses so to the extent
that these are real economic losses
that offset future income this is not
financial wizardry this is just
going back to square one to go back to
the marty ginsburg point
imagine you're at a casino which with
trump that's an actual thing
you start playing blackjack and you lose
a thousand dollars
then you go back to the table and you
keep playing and you actually win a
thousand dollars well
that prior loss of one thousand dollars
will offset the profit
of the future income that you have
winning one thousand dollars
but you're really just back to where you
started so that's why you're able to
use the prior loss to offset this uh
this
gain that you incurred by winning and
that's essentially what's happening here
it's not financial wizardry it's just
going back to square one but it appears
from the returns that trump's entire
business empire was based on exactly
that premise
he runs up big debts goes bankrupt and
then gets to write off those huge debts
for several years then
starts the process all over again the
apprentice was really the first time
donald trump ever hit a bases clearing
home run in licensing
and making enough cash to prop up his
other failed businesses
but by the time that he was president
that money was gone too
and that's why people are freaking out
about the number 421 million dollars
because that's how much donald trump
personally owes to other creditors and
people are worried that this is a
national security issue that
the sitting president of the united
states owes over 420 million dollars to
people unknown including potentially
foreign sources we don't actually know
and it appears that most if not all of
those loans are going to come
due in a balloon payment that will
happen if he's elected to a second term
which is completely uncharted territory
that a sitting president of the united
states
will have to negotiate with creditors
domestic and foreign and of course
people remember that to avoid exactly
these kinds of conflicts jimmy carter
had to put his peanut farm in a blind
trust
to avoid the appearance of impropriety
and this also raises the difference
between the fact that a lot of
corporations the united states
pay no taxes but usually the individuals
the employees and the people that own
those corporations do
often pay taxes the average tax rate for
a millionaire or billionaire in the
united states is about 25
which is lower than the average taxes
that a normal person is going to pay but
still well above the zero taxes that
donald trump has paid for most of his
career
and here donald trump's personal tax
liability is almost inextricably linked
to the trump organization because
they're passed through entities so
there's a big difference between a
corporation like
amazon that gets taxed as a corporation
and an llc which
just the taxes pass through to the
person or people that own it and let's
talk about amazon for a second because
that's an interesting comparison
amazon famously pays little to no taxes
and this appears to be legal but this is
very different from what the trump
organization does
amazon is a business that reinvests all
of its profit back into the business
year after year so for years jeff bezos
was focused on making amazon as big
as possible dominating the online
shopping space to such an extent that
the company was even able to pressure
brick and mortar retailers by
undercutting their profits and the
company did this by aggressively
investing in research and development
and borrowing more and more money to
grow
even bigger if amazon had kept more of
its profits its reported income would
have been much higher and they would be
responsible for paying higher taxes on
those profits
but the trump organization appears to be
a different animal entirely it doesn't
have research and development costs it's
not
buying more and more assets to offset
any particular profit
and donald trump's main plays have
always been in real estate and licensing
and it appears that the losses that he's
reporting on his taxes
are actual losses that his businesses
have been suffering year after year
after year they're not necessarily
paper losses that are offsetting a whole
bunch of revenue in other places
his businesses are generating loss after
loss
and in some cases it's not clear where
the money is coming from to prop
up these businesses that lose hundreds
of millions of dollars year over year
and the bottom line is that rich people
do pay less in
taxes in the u.s but even still
donald trump should have been paying
some taxes and all the tax avoidance
strategies in the world
still don't make this a typical
situation when asked about the tax
returns of the presidential debate
president trump said that he had paid
millions in taxes
i paid millions of dollars in taxes
millions of dollars
of income taxes i paid 38 million
one year i paid 27 million show us your
tax returns
and he might have but almost certainly
not federal income taxes perhaps he's
paid property taxes or payroll taxes but
not
income taxes tax experts say that he can
clear everything up by releasing a
single page of his 1040 to show
just how much he has paid in taxes
without divulging more information
but he has provided no concrete details
to dispute any part of the new york
times reporting
and the worst issue is that many of the
president's properties are being held up
artificially with loans
for many he hasn't paid a single dime in
principle and hundreds of millions of
dollars
in loans are coming due in the next four
years and because the properties are so
risky
trump had to personally guarantee the
loans meaning that even if the property
fails the creditor can go after trump
himself
one might be able to refinance these
loans but that's extremely difficult
when the underlying properties are
losing money hand over
fist and it's completely uncharted
territory for a sitting president to
either renegotiate the loans or have a
creditor foreclose on the sitting
president
not to mention the obvious conflicts of
interest nancy pelosi and other
democrats have called this a national
security issue
he has exposure to the tune of hundreds
of millions of dollars
to whom over 400 million dollars
in leverage that somebody has over the
president
of the united states some have pointed
out that such leverage often prevents
individuals from getting even a security
clearance for the exact same reason
one of the most important things that
the fbi and the background checks look
into
is are you potentially beholden to
anybody
or any entity any country that could use
that leverage
against the interests of the united
states in our national security
in order to extort or exploit or
otherwise manipulate you
though by the same token the total
assets that president trump has are
probably worth enough to cover the loans
if
he liquidated all of these properties
they are not worth what
trump says they're worth sometimes he
claims 2.5 billion dollars
but if you liquidated all the assets it
would probably be enough to cover the
421 million dollars that
is likely to come due in balloon
payments in the next four years but this
is surprising only to people who haven't
been paying attention recall that the
trump foundation charity
was shut down for fraud trump university
paid a settlement of
25 million dollars for essentially
defrauding students though it admitted
no fault
and we already knew that president trump
owes deutsche bank hundreds of millions
of dollars and
the times investigation reveals that his
business enterprises are once again on
the verge of bankruptcy
now there will inevitably be people that
argue that trump's ability to beat the
tax man is just evidence that he's smart
but recall that tax problems are the
ones that brought down al capone
and nobody ever thought that his ability
to evade taxes was a qualification for
president
and it's possible the only difference
between capone and trump is that capone
went to prison
while trump went to the oval office but
that doesn't mean that president trump
couldn't use a refresher on what it
takes to run a successful business
after all he's lost billions of dollars
stiffed banks and contractors and had
many businesses go bankrupt
but the best place for him to brush up
on his business acumen isn't trump
university
it's skillshare which offers classes on
how to manage every aspect of new
business ventures
donald trump has a lot in common with
freelancers who are struggling to
understand the us tax code and the class
bookkeeping for freelancers how to
handle your finances by emily simcox
will really demystify the tax season for
trump and
anybody else the class teaches students
on how to choose the right bookkeeping
method
how to categorize and track expenses and
how to stay organized throughout the
year even in years you're being
impeached or audited
simcox breaks down the ins and outs of
bookkeeping into terms that even a
graduate of trump university
could understand trump could also
benefit from guy kawasaki's skillshare
class art of the start turning ideas
into high-growth businesses so it can
actually start a money generating
business for once
skillshare as you know is an online
learning community that has tens of
thousands of classes on everything like
illustration creative writing music and
productivity the first 1000 legal eagles
will get two free months of skillshare
premium when you click on the link in
the description
and after the trial ends skillshare is
still way more affordable than most
online learning platforms with plans
starting at less than 10 dollars a month
plus clicking on the link in the
description really helps out this
channel
so just click on the link in the
description to get two free months of
skillshare
so do you agree with my analysis do you
think president trump is a tax cheat or
a tax genius
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other law reviews of the
current legal issues including lots of
stuff going on
in the trump administration so just
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court